good morning believe nation today's
messages build your routine over to you
Andy Murray
I think tennis players or athletes in
general love a routine to be honest I
mean I pretty much have stuck to the
same sort of warm-up and practice times
like from playing at four o'clock or
practice two and a half hours beforehand
and I always try and practice the same
at a time before I do the same drills
and practice and all that sort of stuff
and yeah I think it's very important it
just sort of gets your mind and body
ready and aware there's about to compete
and I think it's very important I think
it's important to understand that you
are what you repeatedly do and the
routine and habits that you have make
who you are so if you have a goal to
want to lose weight then what you eat on
a regular basis is gonna be important
you know the occasional junk out it's
not gonna have a big impact but it's
what you do day in and day out that will
have an impact so the same thing in your
business everybody has a routine you
wake up and chances are you do the same
thing pretty much every morning I think
that first hour that you spend in the
morning pot looks the same every single
day and I think too many people don't
have a routine that's set up with
intention I think people just fall into
their habits because it's what they've
always done and it doesn't necessarily
set them up for success so what I
encourage people to do is every month or
every quarter think about what are the
big things that you're trying to
accomplish on a personal level and a
business level what are the things you
want to get done and then look at your
routine and look at your schedule and
ask yourself if I do these things every
day am I gonna move myself closer to
that goal or not and that might force
some harsh reflection on how you
actually are doing things in the morning
what your routine looks like but you
look at people who do have a lot of
success they have a routine and habits
that support that success they have a
goal
then they create a structure that helps
them achieve that goal and I think it's
easy to have these big level goals but
if you're not doing the work you don't
have the routine or the habits to help
you get there you're never gonna reach
it just gonna be some far-off goal so
once a month or once a quarter look at
what the big things are that you want to
accomplish and then do a harsh analysis
on your routine and see if you're doing
the right things every day they'll make
you go closer to achieving that goal so
the question of the day today is I'm
curious what's been one of the most
impactful things that you've changed
recently in your regular routine I'm
curious to find out leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day you seem to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events fest